- Five-Minute Crafts went medical.
Let's see if they're accurate.
Bee-whoop!
Dry hair?
(laughs)
Whipped cream, eat it, and
then stick it on your hair.
This is so ridiculous.
I mean like, look.
People have put fruit juices
and things like that in their hair,
because a lot of the conditioners
just have like fatty acids
in them to replace the oil that is lost
when you over shampoo,
or you have dry skin.
It's just, it's too much.
It's unnecessary.
Okay, this is an intimate setting here.
(laughs)
Do you really need that?
Like, come on.
Well, do you really need that?
Rest it on your lap, for God's sake.
Skiing, take a selfie on the green screen,
have some frostbite, peeling skin.
A banana!
In case you're hungry,
or just put the peel on your face.
Not egg on my face,
banana on my face cause I have frostbite.
Means nothing.
Doesn't do anything.
Ooh, that could be a sign of
a fungal infection or eczema
or just dry skin, obviously.
But let's see what magical
treatment they have.
Oh, put a lemon in your sock.
Imagine that's the solution, man.
Like, no, you got to figure
out why you have the dry skin.
You can't just put random
fruits on your feet
and hope it solves all your problems.
If she had psoriasis, that
lemon would not have helped,
It would have irritated
the area with its acid
and made it 10 times worse.
Okay, we got a painful foot.
Heel, a heel sore or heel blister.
Did she just literally cut
a piece of her bra off?
What's easier?
Let's do a poll right here.
Put a band-aid on your
blister on your heel
or stop whatever is you're
doing, remove your bra,
cut a piece of it off so you
could never use your $50 again,
stuff it in your shoe, walk
around with an unbalanced bra.
What do you prefer?
Oh, my back!
Look at that red spot that appeared.
Look at this bush.
What is she doing with the bush?
Oh my God.
If she eats the bush.
Salt and bush.
It's salt bush.
(crickets chirping)
That will literally do zero.
It won't harm you at all.
It will absolutely waste
your time and do zero.
Not "now better".
Now, total misinformation.
Why?
Ring got stuck?
Okay, my prediction and my hope
is they'll do a little trick
with floss where you actually
wrap floss around your finger,
thereby making it skinnier temporarily
so you can pull it off.
Let's see what they do here.
Oh no, they're going into condom route
'cause it's Five-Minute Crafts.
You're going to lubricate it.
Dude, that was unnecessary.
You could have put lotion on!
It's the same thing!
Why did you waste a perfectly good condom?
Okay, what's happening here?
She's injecting a pad with water.
First of all, where did
you get a syringe from?
Syringes aren't just
sold over the counter.
Freeze
and use it as a cold compress.
(record scratching)
Or put some ice in a Ziploc
bag and put it on your foot.
Crazy, you don't even need the
medical syringe for that one.
Whoa!
Aw, stuffy nose, allergies,
what's happening here?
Okay, the child doesn't want the medicine,
wants the Coca-Cola.
Is this a Cola ad?
What you're putting in.
Oh, that's messed up.
See if I was a kid, I
would be pissed right now.
Not only did you lie to
me, so our trust is broken
and I'm never going to trust you again.
- Emotional damage!
(record scratching)
I'm gonna associate the medicine
with being the worst
experience of my life.
So I never want to take it again.
What you should do is
do a little bargaining,
like give the kids
something positive before
and say, "Look, I gave you
that let's do the medicine",
or at least, "If you do the
medicine, I'll give you that."
How do you even know what this child
is taking the right dosage?
What does her child not have taste buds
that she can't tell that it's Coca Cola.
Activated charcoal, water.
This is the thing about...
Oh my God.
Five-Minute Crafts is so cheesy.
They just try and make you look as visual
and crazy as possible.
The reality is brushing
your tongue, good thing.
When you brush your teeth,
also brush your tongue at
the end of the session.
Like that is a good idea.
I recommend it because
food gets trapped in there.
Most of the bad breath
comes from the tongue,
but activated charcoal,
just going too far.
Like yes, activated
charcoal allows binding
of certain substances,
but it's not gonna solve your halitosis
that's coming from your heartburn.
It's not gonna solve the problem
of the halitosis coming
from your gingivitis,
'cause you don't floss regularly, like me.
Okay, teeth brushing with
some heavy eye makeup on top.
A spoon.
Op, a fake spoon.
Just use your toothbrush for that.
Why did you need to cut
open and break a spoon
that could potentially cut you,
that looks so sharp.
That's an accident waiting to happen.
Don't do that one either.
Headache, grandma comes along,
gives a nice little cuddle.
Has a first aid gift bag
with sparkling water,
gives it to you.
It says not to drink it.
Puts a magic robe over
your head and spills it.
Wait, doesn't spill it.
Lets it sit on your head.
And the headache goes...
What can I say medically about that?
She put a glass of water
on her head on the towel
and said it would make
her headache go away.
In medicine, we don't even
know what causes headaches yet,
but putting a glass on the head.
Imagine you walk into a medical office
and all you see is people sitting
with towels over their heads
with a glass of water
being held on by a nurse.
(machine beeping)
This doctor looks funny
I don't know why.
I'm not buying that he's an actual doctor.
(curious music)
(laughs) He's confused
that the child doesn't want
his heart listened to.
Hydrogel?
I don't know what hydrogel is.
And then you put the balloon,
it becomes a stress ball.
Who has those balls in their office?
You might as well just have
stress ball in the office.
You know what I do,
which is so much simpler,
is I inflate one of
the gloves, tie it off,
and it just looks like a cow utter
and let the kids play with it then.
Roasted red peppers.
Oooh cut.
Okay.
And she's going to cook an egg.
She's going to take
some of the egg covering
and make it a (laughs)
This is so inaccurate.
It's painful.
Just put a bandaid on it and
run it under some warm water.
That's it.
(beep)
Ooh, that's a good stretch.
That is a good stretch.
I'm with a little cat
cow action on the door.
You could use resistance bands
for stuff like this, too.
Sugar, coconut oil,
made a homemade mask for,
what is that?
Stretch marks?
No, you cannot remove stretch marks.
That is actual scarring of your skin.
When it's stretched too
quickly, it's scarred.
There are some procedures
surgically, laser
that can take them off.
Some creams maybe do a
little bit of hiding them,
but removing them full on like that
with any natural product, complete BS.
What do we gat?
Nose, a pimple.
Okay, so there's black heads there.
Essentially, black comedones
are types of acne almost
where you have an opening,
so therefore the oil, or
whatever's plugging the gland,
actually oxidizes and
turns that darker color.
That's why you could see it.
This feels so largely unnecessary.
It's incredible.
If you wanna get rid of your blackheads,
there's strips that you can use for this.
There's a special cleansers you can use.
If you go to a proper doctor's
office, you get a facial.
They would do an extraction
without damaging your skin.
I see people leave such bad
imprints with their nails
in their noses and on their cheeks.
You gotta be really careful
that when you press,
leaving a deep impression like that,
that can cause some real lasting damage.
Dry lips.
That happens, especially
in the winter time.
Oh my God.
She's going with, this
is sponsored by Colgate.
It has to be.
I know some exfoliation on
the lips can be beneficial,
but the idea is you want to hydrate them.
You wanna protect them.
You wanna protect the loss of fluids.
Over licking your lips
can actually cause them
to dry out further because the
water essentially evaporates
and dries out that superficial layer
and it begins to slough off.
Basically this video is just like
all of this subliminal
footage and messaging
to encourage you to brush your teeth.
These individuals have some
super strange addictions.
Let's talk about it.
Click here to check that out.
I'll see you in this video,
staying happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)